have eight companies under you right now
is there like a breaking point where
it's like holy we need more team to
support the amount of companies we want
to have under us right now we run a pod
structure we'll have a handful of people
who are Specialists over a specific pod
it's like you're doing a big meeting
like every day to a point where you have
no idea what's going on with anything
essentially it depends on what the type
of the meeting is if we have a Cadence
to check in on how they're doing on a
Playbook I'm not required for that from
a monthly perspective me reviewing the
numbers we already cleaned the data on
our side so that we can see it the key
numbers that we care about I'm sure like
when you read financials for your own
company it's like I'm not looking at
everything I'm looking at the handful of
things that matter to me I'm looking at
every cash flow I'm looking at growth
I'm looking at sales units I'm looking
conversion numbers and that's about